il est gentil pour deux semaines avec le
club des amateurs pour participer à leur
école vtt au stage de terre vivait à
quelques petites cages
mixez eu encore trois jours pour la
préparation de la voûte ouais c'est pour
s'élever encore une fois le club qui
essaie d'innover
et de nouvelles compétitions on essaie
de mettre en application
thierry qui pourrait ce pont
international voire internationale
il a été le cas voilà le savent parce
que je manquais de participants mais
c'est normal c'est une nouvelle
discipline s avancer mes débuts saison
donc il ya des facteurs qui font que que
le membre soit insuffisant et déjà je
pense que les pilotes ont acquis du
plaisir et j'espère que ça sera une
telle aura pardon au courant de la
saison vous avez trop de points faibles
évidemment la grosse qualité qu'on
remarque tout se sait vraiment leur
explosivité leurs forces sans voilà ce
sont des gamins qui ont des décors aux
valeurs énergétiques de puissance et
ceux qui manquent un peu si on va dire
la place mais technique maniabilité pour
ça encore une fois qu avec le club on
essaie de travailler pour développer des
axes go de terrain de travail technique
pour apporter des bagages aux pilotes
pour les emmener vers reçoit le haut
niveau soit tout simplement se faire
plaisir mais il était vraiment sonné
niveau des jeunes en arrivant ici vivent